is there a way to avoid writing on the-
noose
dialogue yes there with
dialogue obviously the best thing you
can do with dialogue is
recognize when you go out and you listen
to conversation people do not speak in
complete
sentences and you record or you think
about how are people speaking in a way
that feels feel authentic and dialogue
also reveals so much about things like
character traits and flaws and life
phases so you want to think about things
like where is this character in their
life and when I look at the life
process is my dialogue reflective of
where this character is is my dialogue
reflective of the want is my dialogue
reflective of the conflict that the
character might feel internally is my
dialogue reflective you always want to
think something in scene work you always
want to think of is the car is the scene
revealing character while advancing plot
how do you write emotion without stating
emotion that's a great
question emotion all comes down to the
setup of things like the dream the
biggest
fear the audience feeling the void so
when you enter the story you want to
think about the idea of what is making
the character stuck when we enter the
story and the feeling of what is making
story goes into the setup of the
emotional Arc so you're not hitting on
the head what the emotion is instead
you're giving us a sense through subtext
of the void and then you're escalating
the emotional Arc through understanding
what is getting in the way uh with the
void and how the pursuit can help the
character process the past so that they
can move toward the future goal I'm
thinking too about want how do you how
do you state want in dialogue like I'm
thinking back to the to the White Lotus
yes and the Jennifer coolage character
has found this this young woman who will
just sort of listen to her and be her
sounding board but she's also
manipulating her and it's revealed in
these little tells about the business oh
I don't have to we'll talk about that
later right but she she throws it out
and then she takes it away again yes yes
the I think with dialogue the there's a
value in the subtext of the want like
you're describing I also think that the
want is something that you can hit on
the nose with the character just
declaring I want blank and I I think
that that I have seen that done
incredibly well where it's great for the
audience because you clearly know what
the character wants so there's a value
in the subtext as long as we don't miss
the want and there is a value in the
dialogue sometimes defining the want on
the nose for the
audience yeah so you could see both
wants were very clear the the Jennifer
kulage character wanted to be needed and
then the other woman was hoping to make
it out of this sort of Hotel treadmill
of working you know behind the scenes
with these these clients and so both
both wants are very present in the
dinner conversation they I think they'
gone out to dinner yes and yeah and you
could see in those wants and that that's
a great thing to to illustrate you can
see in the wants of those two
characters that it has to with gener of
coolage it has to do with what's making
her stuck and how the dream and being in
business with the other woman could be
an answer for her and for The Other
Woman Jennifer's being stuck and needing
to go in a direction could be an
advantage for her so when you look at
the want I always say when you're
setting up co-protagonist we need to
understand how one is the answer to the
other's
dilemma and that comes down to want like
when you look at the show hacks and you
have a sense of uh Deborah's character
and the idea of of her being in the Life
phase where work is stopping because of
her age and you contrast that with a
younger character who's asked to help
punch up her Jokes which could help her
dilemma and then with the younger
character you also have work is stopping
because of something she said on Twitter
that caused her her career that was
blossoming to suddenly stop so you have
two characters who their wants are in
connection and they are the answer to
the others dilemma what should a writer
know about monologues or should a writer
of try to avoid monologues in their uh
film or or TV or
play I love that question I think that
so many story
experts will say no more than four to
five lines of dialogue so of course when
you hit a monologue You're Going way
over that if the monologue serves the
intention of the story there is value in
the monologue when you look at Aaron
sorin who could have a full page or two
pages worth then it and it serves the
story in such a brilliant way that
brings you to a sense of depth and
understanding of the character there's a
value however just know that the rule of
thumb is you should have four to five
lines of dialogue so the value of
brevity the value uh I often tell
writers you want to look at these big
huge chunks of dialogue and figure out
how you can say the same thing and less
words what is the focal point of the
intention and how can you hit the same
depth because the consequence of too
many words is you lose the focal point
certainly in comedy when you're looking
at Cadence and you're looking at the
Cadence when you have over three to four
lines of diet dialogue you lose that
Cadence the joke gets buried because
there are so many words so so there's a
value in the monologue if it serves the
intention but there's also a value in
can you say something with the same
amount of depth without so many words
yeah I'm thinking one one place and this
is an old reference but say anything
with John qack yes and where he goes on
this sort of tiated about he doesn't
want to you know produce anything you
know you see this guy's like
anti-corporate anti-consumerism like he
he shows that he's this this is who he
is in his monologue yes you know and
here he's got this this woman that he's
in love with who's from like more of a
wealthy family serves show incredibly
well that's a great example that is done
incredibly well because it serves the
story and the character and the audience
because it brings them into that desire
right so it shows it shows kind of who
he is it's very limited and what he
wants to do there's not a lot of room
but he knows he likes being with her but
they you know they kind of come from
these Opposite Worlds and yes and the
polarity going into that
yes